Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Pocas especies en el planeta comparten
un rasgo aparentemente misterioso:
un ciclo menstrual.
Somos uno de los pocos elegidos.
Monos, simios, murciélagos, humanos,
y, posiblemente, musarañas elefante
son los únicos mamíferos terrestres
que menstrúan.
También lo hacemos más
que cualquier otro animal,
a pesar de ser una pérdida de nutrientes
y que puede ser un inconveniente físico.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el sentido
de este raro proceso biológico?
La respuesta comienza con el embarazo.
Durante este proceso, los recursos del
cuerpo se usan hábilmente para crear
un entorno adecuado para el feto,
un refugio interno para que la madre
pueda nutrir a su niño en crecimiento.
A este respecto,
el embarazo es impresionante,
pero eso es solo la mitad de la historia.
La otra mitad revela que el embarazo
pone a la madre y a su hijo en pugna.
Como todo ser viviente,
el cuerpo humano evolucionó para
promover la propagación de sus genes.
Para la madre, significa que debe
intentar abastecer igualmente
a toda su descendencia.
Pero una madre y su feto no comparten
exactamente los mismos genes.
El feto hereda genes de su padre también
y esos genes pueden promocionar
sus propios genes extrayendo
más recursos de la cuenta
de su madre.
Este conflicto de intereses evolutivo
pone a la mujer y a su hijo por nacer
en pie de guerra biológica
que ocurre dentro del útero.
Un factor que contribuye
a esta pelea interna
es la placenta, el órgano fetal conectado
al suministro de sangre de la madre
y que nutre al feto mientas crece.
En la mayoría de los mamíferos, está
tras una barrera de células maternas.
Esta barrera permite el control del
suministro de nutrientes al feto.
Pero en humanos
y en otras pocas especies,
la placenta penetra en el
sistema circulatorio de la madre
para acceder directamente
a su torrente sanguíneo.
A través de la placenta, el feto bombea
hormonas en las arterias de la madre
para abrirlas y asegurar un flujo
permanente de sangre rica en nutrientes.
Un feto con dicho acceso sin
restricciones puede fabricar hormonas
para aumentar el azúcar en la sangre
de la madre, dilatar sus arterias,
y aumentar su presión arterial.
La mayoría de los mamíferos expulsan
o reabsorben embriones, si es necesario,
pero en humanos, una vez que el feto
se conecta al torrente sanguíneo,
cortar esa conexión
puede resultar en hemorragia.
Si el feto se desarrolla mal o muere,
la salud de la madre está en peligro.
Conforme crece, el feto en busca de
recursos puede provocar fatiga intensa,
alta presión sanguínea,
y enfermedades como
diabetes y preeclampsia.
Debido a estos riesgos,
el embarazo es siempre una enorme,
y a veces peligrosa, inversión.
Por eso es lógico que el cuerpo
examine cuidadosamente los embriones
para detectar cuáles merecen el desafío.
Aquí entra en juego la menstruación.
El embarazo comienza
con un proceso de implantación,
donde el embrión se incrusta en el
endometrio que recubre el útero.
El endometrio evolucionó para
dificultar la implantación
de manera que solo los embriones
sanos puedan sobrevivir.
Pero al hacerlo,
también selecciona los embriones
vigorosamente más invasores,
creando un ciclo de
retroalimentación evolutiva.
El embrión tiene un diálogo hormonal
complejo exquisitamente sincronizado
que transforma el endometrio
para permitir la implantación.
¿Qué pasa cuando un embrión
no pasa la prueba?
Todavía podría lograr adherirse,
o incluso ingresar parcialmente
al endometrio.
Mientras muere lentamente, podría dejar
a su madre vulnerable a la infección,
y todo el tiempo, podría emitir señales
hormonales que interrumpan sus tejidos.
El cuerpo evita este problema simplemente
eliminando cada posible riesgo.
Cada vez que la ovulación no termina
en un embarazo saludable,
el útero se deshace de su
revestimiento endometrial,
junto con óvulos no fecundados, enfermos,
moribundos o embriones muertos.
Ese proceso de protección
se conoce como menstruación,
y lleva al periodo.
Este rasgo biológico,
por extraño que sea,
nos pone en camino para
continuar la raza humana.